Update on my life.
Do you see the boxes?
I finally found a place to live as a single mom.
Moving in with my boyfriend for the first time.
So I'm super excited.
I actually think this process of moving in with him
has been really good for our relationship
because we have had to face some stress.
Like, our relationships pretty chill.
We don't really do anything.
There's no stress.
And this was pretty stressful.
Like, every place we went to go look at was, like,
rented before we could move in.
And it would be like, the perfect dream home,
and then we'd be crushed, and then we'd be like,
back, and then it's like,
really been annoying.
It's amazing how hard it is to find a place to rent that's affordable
when you even have, like,
a decent amount of money between the two of you.
So we move in next week.
I'm super excited.
It actually works out really well.
My kids are gonna be going on a camping trip with their dad.
The way it was scheduled is really cute.
It was like his five day visit and then a camping trip, and then his,
like, his summer vacation and then his five day visit.
So it butted up in a really cute way to make it so, um,
they're pretty much there a lot of June.
But that actually worked out in my favor, cause now when I'm moving,
I can do it like Seamlessly and easily
without having to also entertain them and,
you know, keep them busy and safe and happy,
but also move and like that,
do that, like, fucking dance and shuffle.
When someone means to do something for you,
for harm, but you have a good heart,
that shit will always come out in your benefit.
So I am super excited my kids don't have to change school district
because one of my kids is disabled and she's on an IEP.
I did not want her to have to, like,
start a whole new school,
start new friends,
cause she already had to do that last year,
2 years ago or whatever.
So it, like, fits all of our needs.
It even, like,
fixes a few of the issues we have here.
Like, this place is weird. The way you get to the backyard.
I still have to put my dog on a leash.
I can't just, like,
open the door and let her in the backyard.
So, um,
I'm super excited.
And so now we get to all of the packing and all that,
so I will bring you along.
Also, my phone took a shit for a while.
My phone, like,
wasn't really working or help, like,
wasn't letting me record Tik Toks.
So I had to get a new phone.
So there's been a lot that's happened in, like, two weeks or whatever,
so I've missed you.
I love you. I'm gonna get to packing,
but I'm gonna bring you along